je suis vraiment content d'être ici est
donc je suis ici en tant que biologiste
pour vous parler d'un domaine de la
biologie qui est ramot bien qu'il ait
ses bases au xviie siècle avec jean
marty de la marque mais sa domaine de la
biologie qui je pense est
révolutionnaire et qui va je pense aussi
fournir afin permettre les progrès en
médecine rapide et des progrès qui ne
serait peut-être pas possible avec ce
genre de biologie j'espère que dans
l'hypothèse que je vais faire mon intro
qui serait fausse et que ne pas faire
trop d'erreurs
donc nous sommes tous constitués de
milliards de cellules et chaque cellule
contient le bagage génétique faut que
chaque cellule un mot qui contient 23
paires de chromosomes elle ses
chromosomes sont faits de filaments de
la lienne est ce cet adn c'est la
séquence de la nuit les jeunes on a
environ 20 entre 20 et 25 me gêne c'est
ce qui fait notre guinée c'est à dire
c'est notre bagage génétique on hérite
en partie de notre mère est en partie de
faire deviner ou donnent certaines
caractéristiques effet en partie ce que
nous sommes et en fait on est beaucoup
plus que juste nos gènes
notre acquis les expériences de vie
l'environnement les environnements
auquel on exposait dans notre vie s'en
est aussi très important elle détermine
notre personnalité notre bonne santé
notre sensibilité aux maladies
même jusqu'à notre longévité notre du
jeu vies au
il existe un véritable de circonstance
d'expérience fille qui a une influence
que circonstance positives ou négatives
l'alimentation les médicaments l'alcool
le tabac les pollutions
environnementales
les agents toxiques visage le plastique
faut prendre un petit peu plus tard et
aussi ses agents ses expériences de vie
également peuvent affecter toutes les
cellules de notre corps se serait laissé
ou du cerveau et celui du coeur ou
laisser les nôtres même les cellules
germinales simpar productrice est en
fait aussi l'expérience nous affecte
tout au cours de la vie et tout
particulièrement pendant l'enfance et
l'adolescence
parce que notre corps en pleine
formation et le sait lui sont
extrêmement sensibles à l'enfant
or il est clair que l'ine nos jeunes ont
transmis à la régénération
maintenant on puisqu'il est la question
l'hypothèse est ce que noah qui peuvent
également être transmis est ce que par
exemple ce que s'ils repèrent un
véhicule s'ils étaient exposés à un
traumatisme de guerre habitants qui a eu
des effets une force sur sa personnalité
sur sa sensibilité aux maladies ou l'a
rendu dépressif à temps est ce que ce
sont des acquis qui pourrait transmettre
à ses enfants et à ses petits-enfants
c'est une question qui peut sembler un
petit peu bizarre ou incongrues parce
que dans la pensée morale
le dogme en biologie et que le sont les
gènes par les gènes que les choix sont
transmises or maintenant de gym c'est
une idée qu'il veut qui a misé parce
qu'il ya des tas de caractère qu'on est
fiers de nous disposions de l'organisme
maladies qui sont dus l'environnement et
conseillers sont transmises sur
plusieurs générations
donc c'est un concept qui a évolué
énormément m et dans la base du piquet
reste encore un passif ou alors si on
avait cette hypothèse quels sont les
mécanismes possibles
on sait que les cellules déjà pour peu
il est transmise
génération il faut que les cellules
germinales les cellules reproductrices
soit accepté or les cellules en
particulier de plus en plus du bagage
génétique en valière épigénétique
c'est à dire c'est toute une série de
marques biochimiques qui sont sur l'adn
ou près de l'adn qu'il renie fille et
qui en fait détermine l'activité des
gènes les termine sa gêne et activement
et jeunes seules marques épigénétiques
une fouille en sens unique il il existe
plusieurs marques épigénétiques
elle permet le plus important qu'à la
méthylation de l'adn donc c'est une
hérésie du méthyl qui se tuent sur l'adn
à des endroits bien précis
elle a les arn non codants des grandes
molécules die rennes qui existe à
proximité de la d1 qui peuvent s'y fixer
l on peut le contrôler le reggae man en
sciences coup la question est ce que les
marques de génétique peuvent être
modifiées par l'environnement est-ce
qu'elles pourraient être responsables de
fait le type comportementaux par exemple
de la dépression j'ai bien mentionné si
c'est le cas
est ce qu'elles peuvent garder en
mémoire aux gains des mémoires
d'expérience du lit qui ont des effets
négatifs ou positifs de façon à ce que
ça se transmettra de génération a pour
tester cette hypothèse on doit faire
appel où on a beau avoir recours à un
modèle expérimental de laboratoire
c'est pas facile de faire ce genre de
tester ce genre d'hypothèse sur mesure
d'être humains et la souris avec
laboratoire est un excellent modèle pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord on peut
sélectionner celui de façon à ce qu'elle
soit homogène au niveau génétique on a
10 pouces des souris qui sont qui ont
absolument est exactement les mêmes
viennent donc ça permet si on
s'intéresse
génétique de d'éliminer la variabilité
génétique
elles ont fait l'objet on peut
maintenant bien mitigé les différences
de marques épigénétiques
alors avantage de l'assouvir que la
doublette génération est relativement
courte
une souris adultes environ 1 2 3 mois et
on peut générer plusieurs ratés dès la
prochaine et tire sur plusieurs
générations
pas dans la vie d'un chercheur c'est
difficile c'est long c'est coûteux mais
c'est faisable
la dernière à fond avantage il sourit et
si on veut les exposer à un entraînement
particulier ou à l'expérience
particulière on peut faire tous
contrôlés et reproductible à bord de
grands groupes elles et soumettre la
même expérience parce qu'on a faits
doivent entendre en laboratoire et
particulièrement tous là la question des
traumatismes précoce en a mis au point
un protocole qui qui dépend de la
séparation maternelle mais prévisible
quotidien donc c'est un protocole qui
traumatise les souriceaux pendant les
premières semaines de vie si elle
correspond à environ chez l'homme ça
qu'on se rendra du tiers 2/3 de
l'enfance donc c'est leur séparation
l'internet a promis cible quotidienne
qui est couplée à la sépare du stress
maternel à fusil donc c'est une machine
manipulation c'est traumatique
fonctionnel musique et ensuite on
observe enfin on étudie les conséquences
sur le comportement sur le métabolisme
et assurer le fonctionnement général à
travers les générations en croisant les
ados avec des émaux contrôler de façon à
générer la première la deuxième et la
troisième génération c'est un conte
s'est intéressé plus particulièrement
comportement chez l'homme
on s'est connus dans la littérature en
psychiatrie clinique que être confrontés
à des traumatismes dans l'enfance donne
souvent des profils de dépression à
l'âge adulte
donc on peut tester la dépression chez
les chats sont à l'arrêt du tabac
qu'est ce qui t'a mis au point dans les
années 70 ce qui s'appelle qui le teste
hb forcé et c'est ça qu'on s'y penche en
maître l'animal dans un récipient d'eau
froide et volé sur la gauche il serait
normal finage elle essaie de s'échapper
sur la droite une souris dépressive qui
faussent or les animaux qui ont été
soumis à ce traumatisme de séparation de
ce triste internet et sont dépressifs et
cinq sur plusieurs générations
même les arrières petits enfants qui
n'ont pas été en contact avec les mâles
qui ont été traumatisés
même si on les fait adopter par d'autres
femelles
ils sont aussi dépressif que leur
arrière grand père donc c'est indique
que qui a une transmission des appels
espace pas non pour revenir à notre
hypothèse cellulaire est ce que ceci
s'accompagne d'une modification des
marques épigénétiques sur les genoux oui
on a examiné sa sur les galettes l'essai
de l'espoir devenu en particulier et
dans d'autres cellules où inm et on a
servi qu'elle est une méthylation de
l'adn qui est aberrante elle trop de
méthylation de en sortir certains gènes
facile ou de l est les arn non codants
sont en excès de fait 150 ans
maintenant c'est une bonne indication
que les marques épigénétiques peuvent
être modifiées par l'environnement mais
c'est pas la preuve finale pour prouver
vraiment que ces marques épigénétiques
sent responsable de la transmission des
effets du traumatisme un trajet nation
il faudrait être capable de reproduire
ses intentions or pour la multinationale
y est c'est pas techniquement c'est pas
possible parce que dans ce cas là la
mutilation est trop abondante à certains
endroits elle est absente à d'autres
donc expérimentalement par lens
techniquement parlant c'est faisable ou
par contre reproduire un excédent les
rênes
dans un embryon c'est tout à fait ça
aussi c'est une chose qu'on a mise au
point on a tout d'abord extrait les
arènes de cellules de spermatozoïdes de
malte 3 et qu'on a injecté dans des
ovules contrôle fertilisé par les
spermatozoïdes contrôle donc là on a
énormément futur brillant qui est
complètement normal mais il contient
simplement là les rênes de
spermatozoïdes de bâle 3 et après
injection dont les obus la gt on les
transfère dans des femelles préparer
hormonalement par chirurgie et on attend
que la femelle mais pas on attend que
les choses deviennent adultes ont
ensuite tenté soit complètement est ce
qu'on a observé c'est que les animaux
issus de ses yeux à gt sont tout aussi
dépressif que les mages ont extrait n
est également le projet youtube
donc ce qui apporte la preuve que la
rn10 et le germinal est un vecteur et
médiateur de la transmission des effets
du traumatisme
maintenant quelles sont les retombées de
ce genre de recherche pour l'homme aulas
altin antique et rim musique dit c'est
connu que être exposés à des
traumatismes comme accidents du violence
la maltraitance l'abandon la
maltraitance mais ça peut être aussi
l'humiliation c'est à dire des mauvais
rapports entre parents et enfants qui
sow qui empêche l'enfant se développe et
psychiquement parlant normalement ça te
conduire à des maladies psychiatriques
pour la dépression la schizophrénie les
troubles des comportements même jusque
des suicides
et puis on sait que ces maladies sont
transmises à l'original et malgré des
centaines voire des milliers d'études
génétiques on n'entend pas trouvé le
gène de la dépression mieux j'ai de la
slim c'est parce que ces maladies sont
essentiellement à
exposition environnementale des
mécanismes publics de même de nombreuses
études sur des descendants de d'enfants
pendant la conception qui ont été conçus
ou qui ont vécu pour une taille de
grande famille mondiale notamment en
suède et en hollande et descendants de
ces enfants là on ainsi dans ce segment
supérieur de maladies cardiovasculaires
l'obésité est rigolote et sas donc sur
plusieurs générations
il ya maintenant aussi de plus en plus
d'exemples de les conséquences de
l'exposition aux pesticides dont de
nombreux sondés le perturbateur
endocrinien qui ont des conséquences sur
plusieurs générations et également les
plastiques alimentaires ce qui
contiennent de l'eau la france est
maintenant que les effets peut être me
transmettre à la libération
donc quand je vous dis c'est ça un
domaine de la biologie qui est assez
révolutionnaire qui ai l'argent
plus difficile conceptuellement est
pratiquement pas ce que c'est
je suis bien d'accord qu'il ya beaucoup
découvert qui peut se faire par hasard
le nom en l'occurrence le braz a obligé
d'aborder des plans expliqué
expérimentaux des familles racing sur
plusieurs générations donc ça demandait
dans le menton et mais je pense vraiment
que ce genre de recherches malgré toutes
les difficultés et les prometteurs et je
suis moi-même particulièrement engagée
dans ce genre de recherche j'espère que
nos résultats un jour pouvoir en tout
cas apporter des réponses aux questions
qu'on se pose aux techniciens de plus se
pose dans différents domaines c'est cela
la psychiatrie dont je me fasse
particulièrement un psychiatre il
qu'elle soit la psychiatrie métabolisme
les concernent énormément cancer qui
sont dus au fait par an
et que j'espère que nos résultats
pourront aider développement de
diagnostics ou deux approches
thérapeutiques nos futurs merci